marty how does a basketball player
become a filmmaker
very slowly um i i actually didn't get
into filmmaking
until until i finished my undergrad
my last semester of college when i went
to uconn
i had taken a creative writing class and
the professor had been a screenwriter
and i had thought about doing it i
always thought it might be fun i worked
at blockbuster video
when i was in college and you know had a
good time there and
never really thought of it as a
possibility to make a living
but thought it might be fun to take you
know to kind of dip a toe into
so i wrote a screenplay my last semester
of undergrad at uconn
and it was a basketball story actually
it was
a story about a college athlete who
tries to throw the ncaa tournament
uh i can't forget the net what was the
name of it
i can't even think of the name of it but
it was really bad
but i wrote it and it really
i really enjoyed the process of it even
though i knew
you know there was a lot more to learn
so once i got out of undergrad
you know i kind of didn't play
basketball quite as much
started volunteering on indie film sets
just to kind of learn the business a
little bit
um and then i got into uh film school at
florida state
after about three years of that and then
got there and then sort of learned the
ropes and
the whole story kind of started from
there was it inevitable that you would
move to los
angeles was this sort of something that
you knew you were going to be doing
i don't think it was um i always i got
to the point where i knew that i wanted
to make movies
but i wasn't sure if los angeles was
going to be where i ended up
um and i it may still not be
my first time in la was before i
finished up film school at florida state
this was in the summer of 2004.
i came out here and i interned for our
summer and i worked for the producers of
the american pie movies
and had a great time there at the time
it was a combination production company
management company
and so i got to learn both the
production side and the rep side
uh which is really great but when i
graduated
i i really was kind of iffy on it
because
at that time i think i was 27 and i was
really still kind of a northeastern kid
you know having grown up in connecticut
i the city was a lot for me
so at the same time there was talk of a
movie studio being built in connecticut
where that there was a film tax credit
that had just been started
like the year prior and these guys were
interested in building a movie studio
and they wanted to hire local people to
work there
so i took a chance when i graduated and
i actually moved back home
and then i stayed there for about 10
years so
that was sort of the first detour
out of la that i had but fast forward
after those 10 years
the film business had left connecticut
because the film tax credit disappeared
as happened in many states um so at that
point i started thinking
okay do i want to come back do i want to
go to la
do i want to try to work with the
grown-ups you know after working in
independent film for a long time
so i started looking for work and after
about a year of it
i actually got an offer to work in the
film school at chapman university oh yes
i had taught previously but this was not
a teaching position this was a staff
position
in their film school as a production
manager so i thought of that as sort of
the
the catalyst to get me out there and
then i'd kind of see where things went
so in 2015 that was when i moved out to
la and that was when i really you know
decided to make a go of it and try it
here
what would your advice be for someone
that uh wants to
you know dip their toe in the water here
or just come out here because i know
it's it's hectic it's it's hard to find
an apartment it's hard to find a parking
space
yeah and so what what are some tips you
can kind of some
give people to arm themselves when they
come out well i think information is
power
um the more you can set yourself up
before you get here
i think the better off you are when i
came out here in 2015
i already had a job that's a rare thing
i know but even if you're in a situation
where you know if you work at starbucks
you can transfer to any starbucks in the
united states after you're there for a
certain amount of time so if you can
find a place
if you come out here on vacation for a
week and you look at local places that
you think
might be interesting to live in you can
set yourself up to get a job
you know in that area obviously not
everyone works at starbucks but
as the more you can sort of prepare your
life so that when you get here
you're not completely floating in the
wind i think the more effective things
can be
um you know if you're looking on
craigslist if you can find a room before
you get out here
that saves you a lot of stress obviously
any friends that you have any family
that you have
really anywhere in southern california
you know that's a that's a benefit
because
any network that you have here you know
is better than
sort of free floating you know when
you're here when i came here in 2004
i didn't know anyone i i literally just
kind of landed in town and i was
bouncing from
couch to couch of film students that i
had known
when i was living in florida so that
that was not the best way to do it
in retrospect but um you know it was
it took a little time to kind of create
that base so the more that you can do to
sort of set that up before you get here
i think the better off you are what do
you get here in los angeles that you
don't get anywhere else
regarding filmmaking i should say uh i
think
in los angeles there's uh
i don't know what the right word is i
think
in los angeles there's a concentration
of people
that are completely and totally
dedicated to filmmaking
and that's something i haven't found
anywhere else in the country anywhere
else in the world
really um you know this is the the town
where you can go to any bar
and you can find somebody talking about
a new film that they're writing
and if you live in you know the middle
of arkansas
that's that's harder to find
i think being here there's an energy
about filmmaking um that really doesn't
exist anywhere else
i in in my travels around the us that i
found that there are a couple cities
that sort of have an energy all their
own sort of dedicated to one thing
washington dc is one of those cities you
know where everybody there
has a passion for politics and a passion
for public service
here that passion is for storytelling
it's for entertainment
and it really can be a motivating thing
if you're doing if you're making a film
anywhere else in the country
you know in a smaller town it's harder
to find that motivation and it's harder
to find those people that are totally
dedicated to it along with you
so to be able to go to a coffee shop
and to walk in and see somebody working
on their script you know
that that's something that can really
kind of you know buoy you if you're
having a rough time
doing something on your own so i think
in that sense that's that's something
that's really special
about l.a and that being said too uh
i know it's it's hard to get comfortable
here but i feel like once people do get
comfortable
it's it's hard to leave because it is so
hard to kind of like establi
establish yourself what are your
thoughts on just kind of like
keeping moving and and and not getting
too stagnant in one place
for your own growth well i
i think it depends on the person um you
know some people
are very comfortable with setting up a
life for themselves and they're most
effective
when they know they have a base
underneath them um
you know but but the producer of the
movie that i'm working on now
he lives in agora hills and he's been
there his entire life
and he's very comfortable there and you
can tell
that that sort of consistency is
something that he needs
in order to keep functioning at a high
level but not everybody is like that
like for me
i i grew up i lived in a bunch of
different places growing up i was
homeless for a very short time there was
there's a lot
there's a lot of places that i've been
and that sort of kinetic
sort of existence is something that
works for me
that's something that gives me energy so
it really is
you know it is it helps me in my growth
because i enjoy
being in new situations and being in new
places meeting new people
um you know creating new networks things
like that but it's not for everybody
um so it really comes down to you know
who you are
knowing what kind of person you are
being honest with yourself
about that because i had at one point i
had actually tried
when i was working in one place and i
was making a very good salary
i could feel myself kind of establishing
roots in that place
but i knew that wasn't what i wanted to
do so
you kind of if you're in that situation
and you really want to get to where you
want to go
you have to risk ripping up roots
sometimes and going somewhere else and
trying something else
with the hope that that can help you
grow and help you get closer to where
you want to be
so it's really kind of a person by
person decision i think
what's fascinating about you marty is
you've bounced back and forth from
different colleges
and filmmaking and teaching how many
semesters of college would you say you
you've taught all in all i've been
i've been a professor for about
14 semesters yeah when i was at
quinnipiac university i was there from
2005 to 2012. so yeah i was a part of 12
semesters i was part-time for six years
full-time for one
i've worked another two four
yeah i've worked another five years as
staff
in educational contexts so i've been
around for about
between 15 and 17 years i'd say i've
been involved in education
quinnipiac's a beautiful school by the
way yeah it's a gorgeous place
it really is um what would you say is a
difference or or maybe there's not a
difference between
the questions some of these students
have regarding filmmaking whether it's
just for a hobby or a career
you know the the questions are pretty
consistent um
students when they get involved in
filmmaking they have
dreams of becoming the next spielberg or
the next you know
night shyamalan or whoever their
favorite filmmaker is
but they don't know the steps that they
need to take to get from wanting to be
that
to actually trying to be that so i think
a big part of
film students now is just sort of
helping them along the path of making
things that are
slightly bigger in scope and slightly
better as they go along
um technically those questions can run
the gamut you know there are some
students who are wonderfully
visually but have trouble writing some
students are great writers but they
don't understand pictures very well
i was actually like that when i started
because i was a journalist before i got
into filmmaking
it took a while for me to understand how
to tell stories visually
so it's really the the technical
questions are
sort of not as important as it is
helping them figure out
how to get to where they want to be as a
filmmaker
so like when i was a chapman for example
they had a really great process where
when you're a sophomore
you make a four or five minute film when
you're a junior you make a seven to
eight minute film
when you're a senior you make a 15
minute film so that process sort of
helps you expand the scope of what
you're doing
and at every step there's going to be a
growing process because you're going to
be dealing
with things that you haven't dealt with
before so for the three minute film
if if you've never made a film before
you might be
you might have questions about working
with actors because you've never done
that before
and then when you move into the seven or
eight minute film you might now have
questions about working with union
actors
because you've never worked with
sag-aftra and then when you get to 15
the 15-minute film well i've never
worked with a dog on set before so how
do i work with animals
so it's really just sort of helping the
students
understand what step in the process that
they're at and helping them adjust to
the new elements that they're that
they're working with at that stage i
think that's the biggest thing
and speaking of new elements you set off
camera while we were setting up about
how trends
can take a while to seep into academia
and i found that fascinating not
not knowing that world can you touch on
that yeah um
so a lot of the work that i've done in
academia
focuses around crowdfunding and audience
building
especially in the last few years i've
done more kind of lecturing on that
i lectured at the university film and
video association conference last year
in new mexico
on crowdfunding to an audience of film
professors which was actually really
cool
um it usually takes when there's a new
sort of element of filmmaking you know
whether it's
sound and film or whether it's digital
filmmaking
or in my case crowdfunding and audience
development
it takes about 10 years from the
beginning of the use of that concept
to the point where the higher education
community
embraces it and starts to teach it so
this was something i didn't realize this
at first but about 10 years ago when i
was teaching at quinnipiac
i was really trying to get them to
embrace crowdfunding and use it as part
of the curriculum
for their film students but it was met
with resistance because
none of the professors that were there
had actually done it before
so they didn't understand what it was
and they didn't understand how it could
benefit students
and how it can empower them to make
their own content
so fast forward 10 years kickstarter now
you know generates more revenue per year
than the national endowment for the
humanities
now people get it they get it now so
higher education people are now looking
at crowdfunding there's papers being
written about it now
you know it's part of professors paths
to tenure
you know is them sort of publishing on
this so now that it's kind of
seeping into the world of academia it's
now more accepted and it's now being
looked at as something that people
want to teach because they understand it
so that's
it takes a long time to get to that
point um but now that it's here
i think film programs are starting to
look at that
you know if not part of the curriculum
as
something that they need to be
introducing their students to
so like the schools i've worked at it's
very common for them to bring in folks
from crowdfunding companies to do
workshops
so that's a very common thing all the
big film schools are doing that now
so the next step would be can you
introduce that into the curriculum as a
class that you need to take for a degree
so that when you come out everyone
understands the basics of this and
everyone can do it
so we're getting close to that point now
which i think is really exciting
why do you think it takes so long for a
concept
to seep into academia do you think
because it needs to be vetted because
someone can see it on twitter
and and a student and be like oh cool
and then they know about it
but why does it have to take so long to
be vetted sort of
well i think generally um higher
education
is slow to change and it's been like
that for a long time you know
anytime there's new technology anytime
there's new
um new opinion on something it takes a
little while for it to
to sort of become common thought i guess
plus a lot of the a lot of the folks
that work in higher education tend to be
older
and crowdfunding is a technology that's
primarily being used by younger folks
not entirely of course but you know
primarily it's younger people that are
that are realizing the two that
know the tools and that are able to use
them
um a little more efficiently than folks
that are
that are new to them so i think those
are two of the main reasons
and it's not just crowdfunding really
anything that sort of
comes up as a new alternative to things
that folks have been teaching
i think will naturally be met with
skepticism so
in terms of funding the way hollywood's
been run for a long time
is you write a script you find financing
for it and then you shoot it
so the process of being able to say okay
well
i'm not going to wait for that i'm going
to go raise the money myself and i'm
going to use these tools on social media
to do it on my own that's a pretty big
shift and a lot of the a lot of the
professors that work at so you know the
major film schools
they're used to this older model and
some of them have trouble wrapping their
head around it with good reason because
their entire career was based on you
know on a prior model
so i think that i think that skepticism
and i think that that learning curve
is part of what takes it that long for
it to to sort of become
you know a baseline for for higher ed
yeah now they're talking about
blockchain
uh you know like and i'm having trouble
crowdfunding i can wrap my head around
yeah because i was part of a campaign
but blockchain whoo
and then i'm like really feeling dated
with that because i'm having to
like i don't get it i've got to figure
out you know so i can see why
i don't feel like that removed from some
of these generations but then when i see
something brand new that seems so
foreign to me i could see how people
would be
afraid of it yeah and and i think if
you're
if you're an effective educator i think
part of the process of
getting to that acceptance is realizing
that there's going to be things that
come up
that you don't know because there's
other smart people in the world
and and the hope is that if you're if
you're
confident enough in your own abilities
as an educator to say okay
i don't get this you have an opportunity
to find people that are on the cutting
edge of that stuff and bring them in to
show
you that's i think the the really great
educators are the ones that realize that
they don't know everything which is
really kind of a strange way to look at
it but like blockchain being a great
example
if you were to bring in someone you know
who who worked for coinbase or something
like that you know like a crypto
trading currency site or something they
could explain to your students
and by extension you what blockchain is
how it can be applied to independent
filmmaking how it can be applied to
financing
all these different things i barely know
anything about blockchain i own a little
bit of cryptocurrency that's the only
reason i even know what you're talking
about
but i could see that as an opportunity
to bring someone in
and kind of talk about you know what it
is and how it can help you
because i've been through that with
crowdfunding i understand that there's
things i don't know
so the hope is you know if you're a
student
or if i'm a student you know i hope i'm
working with folks who know what they
are talking about but who also know that
they don't know everything
i think that's the best educational
experience that you can get is if you
have
folks that are like that after having
written your own script
having been a college professor you
decided
to go back to school for screenwriting
is it
what made you want to take that leap
what made you
think that you didn't know enough about
the topic
well um so when i decided to go
back to cal state northridge uh for a
second master's degree
um i was met with a lot of skepticism uh
from my friends and my family
and basically everyone i know
for a long time i wanted to be a
professional screenwriter that was the
entry that i had into the business
i started writing first and that led me
to getting involved in production
excuse me i wanted to try to make it as
a professional screenwriter before
making it as a filmmaker but when i went
to florida state
i quickly found out that i was good at
producing
and as people know in the business if
you're good
at something you immediately start
getting work at it and you get
pigeonholed in that very quickly
so that sort of turned me into a
producer and it was hard to break out of
that
i worked for about 10 years as a
location manager a production manager
producer and it was great i met
wonderful people worked on wonderful
films
but that really wasn't what i wanted to
do so that was part of what
led me to try to make rising star the
first feature that i made
because i wrote the script and i wanted
to have it produced so the easiest way
to do that is just to make it on your
own
i say easy
the really the overriding thing was
i know i'm not getting any younger at
the time i was 39
and i thought if i'm gonna do this and
if i'm really gonna dedicate myself to
trying to be a writer
it needs to happen now so after two
years of working at chapman university
i decided okay i'm gonna go back to
school full-time
i'm going to get through this i'm going
to spend two years and concentrate on
writing
and really bettering myself as a writer
it was really
out of a desire to really focus on that
for a little while and then just see
what happens
you know if if nothing happened after
that time i could go back to working and
know that at least i tried
so i got into cal state northridge and
they were kind enough to offer me a job
on the staff of their film school as
well so that was great i worked as a
student resource supervisor there for
two years
i ran their script library which was
totally on brand oh wow
and it was two wonderful years and i
wrote a tv spec
for the show black mirror that placed in
the austin film fest screenwriting
competition
i wrote three features uh one of which
i'm directing right now
um it was it really was the right move
um
it was an unusual move but it did a
couple things like it gave me time to
focus on writing
which was something that i really wanted
to do um
it gave me a chance to kind of reset my
life a little bit because
i was really getting into the producing
track again
when i moved out here because again when
you're good at something and people keep
you on that track
you know whether it's in the business or
academia it's that's very true
um you know and and
it really gave me time to kind of tell
the stories that i wanted to tell
but that i didn't have time to uh the
thesis script that i wrote
which i'm hoping to direct one day uh is
a story about the death of my father
and i had been toying with it for
probably six seven years
but i never had the time and the energy
to sit down and actually write it
and now i do now i can hold it so it
needs work
but it exists and that's a benefit of
going to school
that you know that i think is really
important to me
so yeah that's why what was it like
being a student on the first day
it was interesting the grad program that
i was in we had about
i think 12 students in our class at the
beginning of the program
and i actually wasn't the oldest one
there were
four students that were older than me
three of them ended up dropping out
really over the course of the program
and it was because they had family
responsibilities
they had job responsibilities and that
sort of overtook
their desire to get through the program
so once we
graduated i think i was the second
oldest in the class
so that really wasn't too much of a
transition
like it didn't feel to me like i was in
an undergraduate classroom
that would have been a pretty severe
thing if i was the oldest person in the
class
by 20 years but where there was a big
transition
was where i was working on staff my job
was i was the manager of the script
library at the film school and i had
a group of interns that worked for me
every semester
so i would have over the course of a
semester you know anywhere from eight to
fifteen
undergrads that i'd be interfacing with
every single day
and that was really a big challenge
because i realized very quickly
that i was out of touch with what young
people were
talking about and what they cared about
and issues that they talked a lot about
csun is definitely a very activist
campus yes
so that was something i was looking
forward to being a part of
but i didn't realize just how fervent it
was and being
involved with the students every day and
talking with them about the news and
things like that it really
brought home to me you know what issues
kids care about
and i think that'll help me you know as
i go on you know as a teacher
and you know also just being able to
kind of understand what kind of stories
people are looking for in the film
marketplace
as well so it that was a big transition
uh but i think it was a really good one
yeah a generation x wasn't
really much of a sort of an activist
generation i know our parents were
right but but yeah and and maybe we're
more so now
as as older adults than before but yeah
that's something that i was very
surprised at too to see
how much younger people whatever whether
they're 35
or whatever you know that um care about
it they're very issue based cause based
and i was very surprised at that
yeah and the the neat thing too about
cal state northridge is
how um how diverse the student
population is
um you know obviously i'm a middle-aged
straight white guy
i'm not exactly what they're looking for
but being able to work with
students from all over the world yeah it
really was great like the latino
population
at csun is i it's almost a majority
oh wow yeah they're they're a latino
serving institution as well as a pacific
islander
serving institution so they focus on
working to help those students from
those backgrounds
so every semester i had students from
mexico from spain portugal
puerto rico like from all over the
spanish world and
we would work together and you know we
talk about like what movies did we enjoy
and why did you like that
and you know i when black panther came
out that was a great example
every student of color that i worked
with saw that first weekend and it was a
transformative experience for them
because they had never seen that on
screen before and that didn't hit home
for me until i heard them talking about
it
being frank you know i saw it the first
weekend and i really enjoyed it
but i never thought of it as a cultural
touchstone until i heard
other students of color talking about
how unbelievable it was that they
finally saw themselves on screen as a
superhero
so that was a great opportunity you know
being in that environment
you know some other schools are you know
a little more whitewashed i guess would
probably be the best term
um that that's a great thing to have
been part of to have witnessed
so that that really i mean that helped
me you know in my in my growth
you know as a as a human being seeing
that
were you hearing them on campus not not
just to you
with the interns but were you hearing
them conversations oh yeah
absolutely when um when black panther
came out you know there was there was
that with the african-american community
when captain marvel came out
all the female students that i worked
with were talking about that
you know and you think of these
superhero films as
not really cultural uh
touchstones right but these students are
really taking it seriously because
that's the content that they consume the
most
and when they see these things happening
it's a big deal
it really is a big deal so you know you
so a lot of people sort of
brush films like that off but when you
look at how that audience is consuming
it
it's it's a powerful thing what were
your writing flaws
when you were accepted to the csun
program what did you want to work on
or was it more to just experience
something else oh they're very specific
things
the one thing when i finished rising
star when i look back at the script
the structure of that film could have
been so much stronger
but i didn't know how to get it there
and i
knew it when i watched the film you
could see it that something was missing
and it wasn't wasn't in the way that it
was directed it was not the way that it
was edited or music or anything like
that technically it was fine
because i had great people working with
me but the story
really wasn't enough to keep people's
interest for 90 minutes
so part of me going into csun was a real
desire
to study structure uh and to study
dramatic you know dramatics the basics
of dramatics that was something that i
never really had
when when i went to florida state there
were writing classes but it really was
more
short film based and kind of uh
formula based i guess is the best way to
put it you know like somebody has
a goal they have an obstacle and they
try to fix it all in five minutes
so i understood that but how do you
transpose that into a 90-minute film
where you have to keep somebody's
interest and there has to be a growth of
a character and things like that
i didn't really understand that so and
this is having taught a screenwriting
class before
when i got to this point i still
realized okay i was able to
teach this to some undergrads to the
point where they could understand it in
a short film format but i didn't get it
from the feature length format at that
point so
when i got there part of the reason why
i applied there
was professor edson eric edson he has a
book
on structure so that's specifically like
that's his bailiwick that's what he
makes his money on so i really wanted to
work with him
so that i could really get like a crash
course on that
and it really helped it really really
helped uh and the best part was
that wasn't the only paradigm that i was
able to be exposed to
in the program a number of the
professors that i had
went to usc for screenwriting and they
have a different way that they teach
screenwriting it's the eight sequence
method
i had never heard of that before so
after learning with eric
for a little while then i started
working with these other professors
who were talking about the eight
sequence method and that made even more
sense to me
because professor edson is really
his structure analysis is really
granular it's down to the moment
eight sequence is a little looser it's
not as
it's not as exacting where things have
to happen by a certain point
so the combination of learning both of
those styles
really helped me sort of figure out okay
the stories that i want to tell can fit
into both of these paradigms just not
completely one or the other so now i'm
at a point where when i
when i have an idea for a story i can
sort of see where it fits is it more
according to how eric teaches it or is
it more according to a
sequence so it really is nice now
where i can understand you know there's
a certain kind of story fits a certain
kind of structure
and i didn't get that before so that
going through school really helped me
you know sort of learn to identify that
that's interesting what type of story
fits
one versus the other or were there
movies that plugged into both
there are there's definitely movies that
plugged into both in fact the the eight
sequence method is
you can graft eight sequence onto
professor edson's
uh structured paradigm the difference is
eight sequence can allow you to sort of
go off and follow other characters
in certain moments but then you come
back to the main story after a certain
amount of time and that made more sense
to me
because the stories i want to tell are a
little bit more character based they're
a little bit
looser they're not really the the
tightly structured
narrative blockbuster kind of stories
that's not the kind of thing that i want
to do
and those are primarily the films that
professor edson analyzes
when he talks about his method so to see
eight sequence and to see that you can
sort of take little
side tracks every now and then and go on
tangents before coming back to the main
story
that made more sense to me so but since
i know both of them
you know i can i can kind of see okay
this independent film
goes on you know it goes on different
tangents and goes in different places
but it's still effective because it
follows a lot of the things that are
also common in professor edson's
structure if that makes sense yeah i'm
just trying to think of like would maybe
crash and goodfellas something that has
sort of more of an ensemble cast
fit into that eight sequence yes yes
absolutely ensemble pieces are certainly
uh
eight sequence good ones um you know
road trips can sometimes fit well and
they fit well into both
but i think they work well in eight
sequence
horror film i don't know if you ever saw
misery that's a great example of an
eight sequence film
because when the sheriff goes looking
for the writer
for about 10-15 minutes you're following
that character
you're not following the lead of the
movie and then at the end of that
sequence
we come back to the main story so that's
an example of that
interesting then what what films would
fit more into
edson's professor edson style you think
of you think of any
popular film you know uh that's come out
uh legally blonde would be a great
example of a very
traditionally structured film that falls
into
his style collateral is another one that
does where you have a character
they have a they have a number of
actions that they have to complete over
the course of the film and by completing
those actions
they open up more problems for
themselves and that's what sort of
drives the story
is them overcoming those problems as the
story continues it's kind of it's a
little hard to talk about in the
abstract but it's
professor edson says that every every
major story
hero has 23 major goals that they need
to accomplish over the course of the
film
and then there are certain moments that
sort of shift
what it is that they're trying to get
and then over the course of the film
they learn something in the quest of
trying to accomplish all of these goals
again it's very simplistic but that
that is a little bit more exacting and a
little bit more
i guess i don't know what the right word
is
specific um then eight sequence which is
which gives a little bit more room for
playing around
i think i know he uses uh erin
brockovich
as a which is a fantastic film and i
went after interviewing him
i went back and and watched it and i'm
like this really is an amazing like
susanna grant did such an amazing job
and and even though uh julia roberts
even though julia robert even though the
erin brockovich character julia roberts
interacts with these different people
that have been affected by the situation
it is really mainly her about her
journey as the single mom
as kind of trying to prove herself right
you know and and deal with all these
things that are being thrown at her
so even though you could say well
there's a huge cast that's involved
but it really is her specific journey
right and and so her goals
would be you know to talk with to talk
with one of the victims of pg e
right and then based on that she learned
something
which he calls fresh news i don't know
if you mentioned that um
and then that uh motivates her to the
next goal
so if she learns something with this
first client then her next goal is to go
to
um city hall to look at topographical
maps of the city to find out where
things are you know and then she learns
something there
and that gets her to another goal so
that's sort of the the step-by-step
process that professor edson teaches and
it's there
you know when you watch erin brockovich
it's all there and through those goals
she learns to have the self-confidence
that she never had when she was a kid
right and she based it on her looks and
she still uses that when she goes to the
city hall
she's such a great scene right right
right and with that mastery too
uh-huh right that's true and then she
goes back to law office and then they're
all giving her these dirty looks but
she's still trying to prove you know
with albert finney's character that like
let you know let me keep doing this let
me keep doing this and it's a great
it's just a great uh character study yes
it really is yeah it's a beautiful film
what was the application process like
getting accepted into
the csun master screenwriting program
well
um it was one of a couple schools that i
applied to
um i had applied to ucla
the university of texas cal state
northridge and cal state fullerton
it's a pretty simple process you have
you know information that you fill out
about yourself you'll hand in a resume
so that people will understand you know
what your work history is
some schools will ask you for writing
samples the university of texas asked
for a feature
which i sent them which i had and then
csun had asked for two things
they asked for a 30 to 45 page writing
sample
for which i sent them a tv pilot that i
had written
and then they also asked for a specific
five
page scene that goes that has to follow
certain parameters that they give you
uh in this case i think it was two
people come home
and they find uh from the airport and
they find that there's a piece of
luggage that they had
that's actually someone else's and where
does the scene go from there
oh so that was kind of neat i i played
around with that a little bit and
i came up with this idea that the uh the
piece of luggage that they had
actually contained the cremated remains
of someone they didn't know
and it turned into an argument between a
husband and wife because
one's mother had passed recently and
they had an argument about what they
were going to do with her remains
so it all kind of tied into that wow so
that was fun
so i ultimately i got accepted to
northridge
and i also got accepted to fullerton
which was cool and i got a chance to
talk with
the head of the program at fullerton
who's a wonderful gentleman um
his name is bob i used to write for twin
peaks oh wow back in the day
um but ultimately i decided to go to
northridge because they offered me a job
in the film program
as well and it's a beautiful campus as
well i'm sure fullerton is too but i
haven't seen it oh fullerton's beautiful
csun is beautiful csun also has a 300
000 square foot gym
oh nice uh which i took advantage of
every day my first year before i really
got into working
um so yeah it was it was nice it was
definitely the right decision
that it was the right campus for me to
be on the right time for me to be there
so i'm really happy with the decision
that i made i know we were talking about
the competitiveness
of california and just how difficult it
is to
find a job or an apartment whatever
whatever
it wasn't guaranteed as well that you
would be accepted into these programs
not at all not at all um it and some of
these schools have very
a very high number of applicants um i
know ucla
they get i think it's thousands of
applicants uh for
i think it's 12 spots in the graduate
program each year
um so for yeah for writing it's it's an
extremely competitive program
and then what ucla does that's
interesting is they have the extension
program
great program so if you don't get into
the main program you can go into there
and then still you know work with their
professors and still create work
through the school which is great and
that was something i had thought about
as well
before deciding to go back full time
the um the reason csun and cal state
fullerton were high on my list
was because they had wonderful faculty
and they're the most affordable masters
of fine arts screenwriting degree in the
country
in the country if you're if you're an
in-state california resident it's the
it's the most affordable program in the
u.s
wow i would not think that a place in
los angeles would qualify for that
that's interesting
that's the beauty of california and the
amount of money that they put into
education the amount of subsidization
the government has
it allows somebody to go you know
through the program and for me
i went two years for a graduate program
and it cost me i think just under
fifteen thousand dollars
really it was fantastic it was really
wonderful
oh sorry as someone who had a lot of
student loans before you know that's
that's something that really mattered a
lot to me was i wanted to get through
this with no debt
and that was something i was able to do
and
northridge is great because there's so
many things i mean it's not really a
small town it's a sense that there's a
lot
there's you know you're close to so much
it's not like you're remote yeah it's
great and and the fact that i lived in
northridge when i was a student there as
well
i never had to use the freeway and that
was just
such a godsend so that was great
we'd love to hear about your first day
and actually week
in the screenwriting program what were
things that were taught or were they all
introduction into what you'd be learning
um
it was a little bit of both um we had
the first semester we had three classes
um we had an introduction to screenplay
analysis
and that was with professor edson and
that was the beginning of
his sort of explanation of of screenplay
structure
we didn't actually write in that class
but that first class was sort of like
a top-level introduction to the terms
that he would be using
um kind of a general overview of what
the structure paradigm is
uh and then sort of an assignment where
we had to watch a film
and then break down the first act of
that film of what happens in every
single scene
and so that sort of built onto more
things that we would learn later where
we would do breakdowns of entire scripts
of entire films but that first class was
just sort of
an introduction of terms and a basic
overview of what the structure was
we had a class called
the short screenplay and that was a
class where
we needed to write a 30 to 45 page
script
that could be anything it could be a tv
pilot
it could be a beginning of a feature it
could be
a web series pretty much whatever we
wanted but that was taught by another
professor his name is jared rappaport
a much more freer sort of experience
he's a very he's i love him so much he's
such a great professor
he he's definitely the opposite of
professor edson
and that he's very free-flowing and he's
very
you know follow your muse and follow
your inspiration and stuff like that
um and every bit the successful
screenwriter that that professor edson
was
um but we started that first class with
some guided meditation
oh cool if that's any guide to what that
was
and it was just sort of us talking about
ideas and sort of tapping into
the things that make us want to be
writers and the stories that we want to
tell
so it was much more sort of an
individualistic
class and figuring out what it is that
you want to say
so that's what that was it was a you
know a couple exercises and
in figuring out what are the the
conflicts that you're most interested in
what are the types of people that you're
most interested in and then based on
that
you sort of figure out and you sort of
back into
a writing project that will help you
explore that
so for some of us like i ended up
writing um a spec script for an hbo show
called room 104
that that dealt with a dysfunctional
family because that's that's kind of
the thing that i'm really interested in
other students wrote the beginnings of
features like the first acts of features
that sort of stuff
but there were all different types of
projects there and then the third class
uh was the one hour drama class and that
was taught by a woman named lawrence
walsh hodson
she was a story editor on csi miami
and she worked on a number of other
shows as a tv writer
and that was sort of us coming up with
the show that we wanted to write a spec
for
so any one hour show we could write for
and it was us just sort of talking about
the different types of one-hour shows
the different genres um you know
serialized shows
um versus you know kind of case of the
week
shows and really just sort of that first
class was sort of boiling down
what we had wanted to tackle for the
semester
and just sort of talking about life in
the writer's room and stuff like that
so that was fun i ended up picking uh
black mirror as a show that i wanted to
write a spec
for because there's a structure to it
but every episode is unique
and not really connected to the others
so i
was kind of cheating i wanted to write a
story as a feature so i thought if i did
it as a black mirror spec that would
work
so yeah those were the first three
classes that week um
it was that first week wasn't that
stressful because
as all semesters you have sort of a
beginning and intro
before you really get into the work and
the real meat
of the of the semester but it was a
great sort of
you know first step into you know what
would be two years of studying writing
and what was that first movie that you
watched that you dissected
do you remember the first one we watched
i believe
was legally blonde oh great i think was
the first one that we did yeah that's
awesome
yep and what were some of the terms that
you were introduced to
you said there were was it screenwriting
terms yeah yeah so for professor edson
there were a couple terms specific to
his book and specific to his
analysis um any time a hero has
something that they're trying to do or
that they're trying to
learn about he calls that a hero goal
so the main character in your story is
trying to do something at the very
beginning of the movie
right so uh in the case of um
legally blonde reese witherspoon's
character is getting ready for that
date that she's going to have with her
boyfriend that she thinks he's going to
propose to
her at right so she's getting ready for
it
and then at when she actually gets to
that dinner
the boyfriend breaks up with her so
that's
what she learned was that okay her
her goal is obviously not going to
happen because she got news that
completely changed it
that news he calls fresh news
so whenever you get fresh news you now
move on to a new goal
as a result of what you've learned so
after the breakup
reese witherspoon's character decides
okay i have to find out why he's
breaking up with me
so the goal is then to learn why her
boyfriend is breaking up with her
and then as they're driving home she
figures that out
and then she decides okay the reason she
learns that
he's going to law school and that she's
not the right kind of girl for him
so once she learns that her next goal
is okay i'm going to get into law school
so i can prove to him that i am the
right kind of guy or right kind of girl
for him
so based on the fresh news of okay
and he he's breaking up with me because
i'm not in law school
her new goal her third goal is now i'm
going to get into law school myself
and then that continues all the way
through the film and it evolves
she gets into school she finds out he's
already engaged to someone else
then she ends up working you know she to
prove to him
that she's really the right kind of girl
she gets an internship at a law firm and
then gets involved in a case and
you know so all of that is to to prove
that she really has the wherewithal
to be a good to be a strong person to be
you know a smart effective person and a
good lawyer
so that's the journey she goes on as a
result of all of these actions that she
takes
how has the screenwriting masters
program transformed
your screenwriting process what do you
do differently now
well i i think a lot more about the
structure from the very beginning
um than the way that i used to do it um
previously i would start just by sort of
if i had an idea for a movie
i would just start writing and just sort
of see where it went
and sometimes good things would come
from that there definitely is a benefit
to sort of free writing and just you
know kind of seeing what comes from it
but my experience has taught me that
spending time to outline an idea
before actually writing it makes the
writing much more efficient
um i i've saved multiple drafts
of screenplays because i've gone and
i've outlined ahead of time
and i figured out the the major you know
turning points of the film and that sort
of thing
that's something i really didn't do
beforehand because
i sort of rebelled against it i thought
that you know structure is the enemy
and the thing that i've learned is
structure is your friend
it helps point out errors before you get
to them
and it helps you helps you stay on track
if you know what the next thing is that
you're writing towards it's a lot better
if it's five pages away
than if it's 50 pages away so you know
that you have a specific thing to write
to
your scenes have more urgency your seams
your scenes have more conflict
as a result of that so that's i think
that's the biggest thing that i've
learned
and the other thing that i sort of
picked up along the way is
the more personal that you can make your
stories and the more raw you can make
them
i think the more effective they are for
the reader
the story that i wrote about my dad
there were some really dark things that
were in there and it's not a dark film
per se
it is a drama um but really laying
bare some emotional things that
that i had dealt with you know a long
time ago
it really helps with the you know it
helps with the writing it makes it more
it makes it more engaging it makes it
more interesting
for the reader you know the more you try
to cover up
sort of the raw things that your
characters are dealing with
the less interesting it becomes so i
think i think it's good to kind of lay
it all out there it's kind of a form of
free therapy
i know you'd said another class from
another professor that they talked about
deciding what type of protagonist you
really want to focus on
did you did you start to see parallels
and who you wanted to write about
and you know it's funny i i have
and i see it now in the film that i'm
that i'm making now
that it really is even though the
characters in this film that we're
making now
have nothing to do with me and my time
in my life because they're all in their
20s
their struggles are exactly what i'm
dealing with now it's it
really is interesting how subliminally
you sort of inform your work with the
stuff that you're
dealing with in your life and you know
the issues that you really
care about and that you struggle with
it's it's really an interesting thing i
thought i was trying to get away from
that but you really can't
it really was there so you see that
a lot of the movies that you've been
drawn toward have a similar protagonist
i think so yeah you know people that are
trying to do good
um but that have come from really hard
scrabble really
struggling circumstances you know either
emotionally or socioeconomically
those are the kinds of characters that i
really i really gravitate to
um you know one of my favorite films
ever was a film called short term 12.
that was brie larson's first real
leading role uh before she got into a
room
at one of the oscar and that film is
about a woman who
works at a home for troubled teens and
she herself was a troubled teen when she
was growing up
so she's sort of enmeshed in that world
and she's struggling to get out of it
you know
but it's hard because you know you're
surrounded by all this trauma
um you know that that really resonated
with me because
it's sometimes it's hard to break out of
that kind of life when you grow up in it
and eventually you know her character
does she does move on
in a way um so it's that that was a film
i really loved so those kinds of
characters
you know that are really struggling with
moving on
from a world that they know even though
it's negative
that kind of story really connects with
me
i think a great story needs
at least one great character who wants
something so badly that they're willing
to risk everything for it
um that creates the drama and that
creates the interesting situations that
that create so many great films
and it could be anything you know it
could be creating a
an island of dinosaurs or it could be
you know someone just wanting to move on
from a life of trauma
you know anything big or small it there
needs to be that overwhelming desire
to to get whatever it is that they that
they want so badly
that's the first thing and then the
second thing is you know you need forces
against that character
that are almost as strong as they are
i some people say every bit is stronger
stronger
i i wonder about that like there needs
to be a weakness
in in these obstacles that the character
is able to identify and exploit
in order to move on um
you know if you got those two things i
think you're off to a great start and
then i think the third thing
is a viewpoint on the world
from the filmmaker or the storyteller's
perspective
uh that's unique and and that could be
anything
you know it could be it could be an
interesting way that people talk
it could be the way of life in a
particular part of the world
something that makes that story
something you haven't seen before
but that you feel that you've seen it
um before the way i like to describe it
is that if you know if it rhymes with
the truth
then it's something that's that's really
effective i heard greta gerwig say that
when she was talking about writing
ladybird and that she said that that
script wasn't exactly her experience but
that it rhymed with the truth and i
thought that was really cool
um so yeah i think if you got those
three things i think you're in good
shape
i'm thinking about the the adaptation of
um
john krakauer's book with christopher
mccandless so into the wild i know
that's a few years ago that came out but
to me that's just such an
amazing uh character journey and
although it's it's a sad movie but
there's so much in that
and there's so many elements to it it's
not just him braving
the wild but also being exposed to the
city like one of my favorite scenes
is him looking into that like la bar and
you can see the reflection
and just see so much and that look on
his face on emil precious face and it's
just that's to me such a great
you know again it doesn't end well but
it right
but it's a great journey of discovery
like you remember the time when he was
in slab city
in that film you know that not only is a
journey of discovery
for him but how many people have never
heard of that area before
that's the first time they've ever seen
it you know yep
right and rubber tramps like i didn't
know and i was like oh okay yeah that
makes sense that's like the
such an interesting uh world yeah
how should a writer begin a movie a
writer should begin a movie
with an event that captures your
attention
it could be something audacious it could
be with a car exploding
it could be with an interaction between
two people
that is a major interaction for their
relationship
it could it's it needs to start with
something that upends the world of the
character that you're following
and i think from there everything sort
of goes
smoothly from there if you start with
that and thinking of
an older movie um sunset boulevard and
how the movie is essentially bookended
by the same thing happening but you you
see the consequence
you see the ending in the beginning and
then i find that very interesting
because then you're piecing together
well how did how did this happen i mean
you know the screenwriter seems so nice
like what what happened who was it you
know
right right yeah i mean so many movies
are like that you know you start a film
with a murder and then it's like okay
that's important
but now we get to see how it all came
together and why it happened
yeah right and so what about
the use of too much conflict in the
beginning or is there no such thing
honestly i don't think there is such a
thing as too much conflict
i think there can be conflict that takes
away from the main storyline
that's something but i think in general
the more you have characters with
opposing world views and opposing goals
i think the stronger the film becomes
and that was something that was
something i learned after rising star
my two lead characters they had one
major
difference of opinion and that sort of
drove the film
but there wasn't enough there needed to
be more
and that that was something like when i
got into csun
i could see it in my own writing and the
stuff that i wrote after that i really
made it a point
from the very beginning there needs to
be something
you know that's that's talked about and
or that's
seen you know between characters where
there's problems
because the problems are where the
conflict come from and the stories where
the conflict
the the story is ultimately what comes
from that conflict
that's how they deal with it we see that
too in uh documentaries don't we where
there's there's kind of like a conflict
or there's the tension of kind of what
happened
in the very beginning of the film and
then it goes back
oh very yeah very common which part of
the screenwriting process
is most difficult for you i think the
revisions
are the hardest part for me um i've
generally
been pretty good at being able to write
a first draft of something
because of my background as a journalist
i'm used to just
kind of spitting out thoughts and just
kind of getting them out very quickly
so i can write a first draft usually
with pretty quickly it's when
you finish that draft and you have that
moment of oh my god this is so great i
just finished this
and then that thought turns into but you
know this needs to get fixed
and going back over and finding the
moments that don't work
and introducing theme and you know
strengthening supporting characters and
things like that and making every
character integral to the storyline and
cutting characters that you don't need
all of those things are tough for me
because
now the way that i write i try to
outline as much as i can
before i start so when i have that first
draft i think well this is actually
really a second or third draft because i
did all this outlining work so this must
be
much closer to finishing you know than
it would be and then i read it and then
i realized it's not
and really kind of bearing down and
doing that really
fine work of you know cutting
the the sentence of dialogue that you
don't need um
you know finding a way to get rid of the
widow so you have one line of action
instead of two you know those those
kinds of things
that takes me a lot of time um so i
think that would be
the hardest thing for me do you do you
do the whole
like put it in a drawer from you know
the cliche
put it away for a month or no sometimes
uh it depends on the story like i have i
have one script i've been working on it
for
gosh i think seven years now and i'll
write a draft
i'll put it away i'll go do something
else i'll come back to it
i think i'm on draft eight right now and
it's taken a long time and it's it's
changed
quite a bit from what it originally was
and i think it's still going to
change because i started writing it so
far before i went to school
now i look at it and i say okay now
there's some really big things i can
change
and this that would make it a lot better
so yeah i mean sometimes
sometimes i put it away for a little bit
and sometimes i put it away for a really
long time
it sounds like that script means a lot
to you um
or it's just something it's it's
something that i know
if i do it right could really help me in
my career
so for that particular script
i want to make sure that when the world
sees it it's as good as it can possibly
be
because every time i've pitched it
people love the idea
literally every single time i have yet
to have a negative reaction to this
so my response to that is okay i'm gonna
sit on this and i'm gonna make sure
that when it does go out into the world
it's ready and it's there's not a word
out of place
so there's still a ways to go before i
get to that but
it's getting there in your mind marty
what's the purpose of story
i think story exists to remind people
that we're not alone
um i every time i see a film that really
connects with me
i i always think that okay someone else
is dealing with something similar to
what i am
um or someone's thought you know a way
about life
the same way that i have you know story
is is a way to build community
and that's something that connects not
only to the
the film that you watch but also the way
that you make it
you know so much of of indie filmmaking
now is is about community building
um but in terms of you know the story
itself it's
it's a way for people to to realize that
they're in a lot of ways we're all the
same
do you think that's why it's a richer
experience seeing it in a theater
i think so i in in certain ways
um i think
i think you get more out of seeing uh
like a real good drama or real good
comedy with an audience
um well nice let me rephrase that
yeah i think i think seeing a film in a
theater is a really powerful way to
connect with that community
like i still remember in 1999 i think
when there's something about mary came
out
i was living in florida and i went to go
see that in the theater
and to this day i have never laughed so
hard in a movie
and part of it was because everybody
else was laughing
just as hard so that was just an amazing
experience
when the south park movie came out i
think it was that same year the year
before
i remember that there were people
standing up and cheering
you know at parts of that film like it
was it was just really
it was hilarious and it was it was
cathartic
you know for everybody that was in there
just a chance to really have a good
laugh
um yeah you know and you can it carries
all the way to this day i saw a film
called the farewell
last week at the alamo drafthouse and
that film was
just a beautiful story about a chinese
family
and how the american member of that
family has to go over to china
and deal with a family problem there and
it was even though it was
about a chinese family it was universal
because the drama within the family is
something that
so many people know and in that
experience
being in that theater and it was a
packed theater it was great like the
moments of pathos were strong the
moments of humor were strong
and at the end of the film you know
people were talking about it like i was
talking with the folks that we were
sitting next to
and you know have never met them before
and you know here we are with the shared
experience you know
it's something you know the netflix's
and amazons of the world are going to be
here forever
but there is still something really
special about seeing a film in a theater
there really is and it's nice when you
can
just turn to the person next to you
afterward and just or even just seeing
the sort of the demeanor of people
leaving the theater
you know because there is in la it is
tough with like there's this whole new
cell phone etiquette that a lot of
people just don't
sort of regard so there's that part but
once that's all over and everybody kind
of puts the phone away hopefully
then then you know we get to this part
where you can really see is it affecting
people
and it's interesting when you're
laughing at a part that other people
aren't sometimes i wonder are they just
restraining themselves
or you hear sort of moments of shock
there's been
films and i won't go into them what they
are because they're very political
but where you can tell you can see the
outrage
just by a gasp from from someone but you
know what that's another part of the
experience
you know the the community aspect
doesn't always have to be positive
i i saw uh when fahrenheit 911 came out
i saw that in the theater and people
broke out
into yelling matches after the fight was
done
wow and to me that was wonderful
because yes it's stressful because
obviously people
with with different beliefs are going to
be very vocal about them and thankfully
it didn't devolve into an actual
physical
altercation but that that's the power of
movies
that's the power of cinema is to to get
people
emotionally engaged and whether you're
on the same side
or if you're on different sides it's the
engagement that's the most important
thing
and so obviously i'm on one side of that
for that particular film um
and there were folks that i was
supportive of in that yelling match
but you know the fact that we were
involved that's why that film was made
was to generate discussion was to to
generate not controversy but
although of course it had it but you
know get people talking
and so that film did its job you know in
that particular screening
so and i think i think that's what
filmmakers should shoot for is that
level of engagement you know in whatever
form
whether it's communal or whether it's in
the moment
divisive i think either one is is
totally valid
where was this uh this was in
connecticut
yeah and this was after the screening
yeah yeah
and did just curious we'll move on but
did security or ushers have to come in
there were folks watching but like no
one you know no one actually threw a
punch or anything like that
so there was it just sort of it happened
they yelled and then everyone just kind
of went their separate ways
so to me and i know a lot of people
won't say this but
i look at that as a positive because
everybody gets a chance to kind of get
their views out
and you know it makes people a little
uncomfortable for the moment but
do you want that or do you want people
sitting and stewing you know
right and the one i'm thinking of which
was more recent
i usually like to clap after films and
i'm always amazed
when people don't but no one wanted to
clap after this film
so i was like i think maybe i'll just
keep my my clapping to myself
okay all right i don't want to be
outnumbered here so yeah
how do you improve or make a story
better
well there's a lot of ways that you can
make a story better um
the the most effective way i've found
is to make it shorter um
the thing i've learned one of the big
things i learned at csun was that
there can't be any superfluous moment in
a screenplay
because the attention of an audience is
so
short you need to constantly be showing
them
what the next step is what the next
question is what the next mystery is
there's not a lot of time for you to go
on tangents that are not directly
related to the story of the film
now i talked about before being able to
go on tangents
through the eight sequence method in
that case
even the tangents are directly related
to the main storyline in some way
so like in the case of misery when we
follow the sheriff
as he tries to figure out what's going
on with this missing guy
and he ends up going to the house we're
not following the main character
but we're following a character that's
going to come in contact with that
character
so it's it's vital that every single
scene
be directly related to the narrative
spine of it um
you know finding a way to make all your
characters unique
um is something that's always good one
of the common
tricks that i actually use and that's
actually very effective
is if you write a scene and if you cover
the names of all the characters
if you read the scene just the dialogue
and you don't immediately know who the
characters are based on what they're
saying
you need to go back and figure out a way
to write it so that it's specific to
that character
and that's a very effective way to kind
of improve the uniqueness
of the characters in your story you know
whether it's by changing the cadence of
how they talk
whether it's changing the point of view
of what they're saying
you know figuring out why they're saying
it um it helps to deepen
who those characters are those are those
are some ways i think that can help
talk about sort of you know like cutting
the fat to speed it up
but one thing i i love and i feel like
we've gotten too fast-paced with some of
the movies and maybe that's just because
of
i'm in a different generation you know
but it seems like it's a real art form
to actually have it be fast enough for
television let's say like sharp objects
it felt
like a slower pace thing but i get it if
you broke down
just all the different scenes and
sequences and and you know shots and
stuff
it was probably very quick but there was
a slow feel to it
and uh the last black man in san
francisco there was a slower feel to it
but i mean i'm sure if you boiled it
down it was actually quite fast-paced
but i think that's a real art
oh absolutely and part of that ties into
the way that you film the story
you know you think of like big little
lies there's
that to me didn't feel all that
fast-paced because you have a lot of
scenes you know with like nicole kidman
for example in therapy those scenes even
though they're vital to the story
they don't lend themselves to snap bang
fast action storytelling
so the the type of story that you're
telling
can help to affect the pacing of it even
if it is properly structured in the
script
the way that you film it can have a big
effect on that that's true because i'm
thinking of like the different women in
there and they're sort of
their emotional uh wine drinking scene
where the beautiful ocean like a lot of
them seem to have these great scenes i'm
like
wow i wish i could live there but you
know so and then they're having this
sort of meltdown and the husband is like
honey it's okay you know and it was very
uh it felt very slow moving but i get it
it probably was was just a quick moment
yeah yeah and it's all the style of
filmmaker too you know i
one one film i think of a lot in terms
of that is the big lebowski
so that film if you read the script the
script moves pretty quick
but if you watch the film the film takes
place in a lot of single shots
and it moves very the camera moves very
slowly as the characters progress
through the scene
so that has a way of slowing things down
a little bit
so even though the script is very tight
every scene ties in directly to to what
the main story is
even though like you can see meandering
because of who the character is
everything's there but the way that the
cohen shoot
it's almost kind of theatrical where
everything is taking place within a
single frame
and characters are moving within and out
without any cuts that can give the
feeling of a slower pace
so it's it's a filmmaking thing more
than it is a screenwriting thing
okay interesting yep
how do you decide a story's ending i
think deciding your ending is one of the
first things that you should do when
you're thinking of a movie idea
because audiences can forgive slow
beginnings
they can forgive muddy middles but if
the film doesn't have a good ending
you walk out of the theater with a bad
taste in your mouth
so i think that's something that you
really need to think of right from the
get-go
and also because that helps you
build towards something if you know what
the ending of the film is when you start
writing it
you you have your son you have the major
signpost
of what you're building towards and i
think that's really important
because a lot of films sort of fall
apart in the second act
because they don't know where they're
going but if you know right from the
get-go what the ending of the film is
you can you can you know what's up
farther ahead
so and then you can sort of build your
sequences around that and then build
your scenes around your sequences
knowing that everything is leading
towards a very specific endpoint
i think that's really important and so
by outlining
that's where you would discover it
absolutely yeah
and it's nice outlining is good too
because you can see
if an ending that you've picked doesn't
fit with the rest of your film like a
writer may decide
there's a moment in the second act that
i have to build this film around
which is great you know if it's
something that you're really passionate
about
but it may not work with the ending
you've chosen so by outlining
you can decide okay what are the moments
that i'm going to be building this film
around and how can i get those moments
to help me towards a satisfying ending
if that makes sense have you heard of
the 24 uh plot points
doing it that way we spoke to another
gentleman who's a writer and an
instructor or a professor
and he talked about the 24 plot points
i may know them under a different name
oh okay maybe that's it
yeah so you're writing down these 24
points and then
plugging in the different things so that
might be actually very similar to
professor edson's
uh process because he has 23 hero goal
sequences in a film
okay so that could be pretty close to
that interesting and so that's done
sorry in the beginning so you're mapping
that out
okay and that's your that's sort of your
guide your map
interesting okay and so then that 23rd
or 24th
that's your ending that's your yeah i
mean
normally normally the the last
three to five hero goal sequences are
your ending
so it's not one particular moment but
it's your third act
right so you understand what's going to
happen in your third act as far as what
the major
action through line is and then also
what the emotional
sort of wrap up is for these characters
does this character get what they want
do they get what they're fighting for
have they learned anything through the
experience and you don't have to
necessarily
i mean that's how seinfeld was on the
air for 10 years you know
that however however you want to wrap up
the story
that act is where all those events take
place and that's where all those
questions are answered
so that's that's kind of the zone you
know where you can answer those
questions
so let's say 19 through 23 or 25
yeah yeah it's the according to
professor edson
uh the first act has six euro goal
sequences
the second act has 12 and then the third
act can have anywhere from three to five
so yeah that's usually how it goes so
when you begin outlining
do you go straight to those last five
or no you're just going in order not
always
um like for for the script that i've
been working on for seven years
i knew what the ending of that film was
right off the bat i knew exactly what it
was
and the struggle since then has been how
do i build the film to that
so other films you know i have an
opening image that i think is really
cool
and that i start with that but then i
have no idea where i'm going so it's you
know it kind of depends on the story you
have different inspirations and you know
you have different ideas
of elements that you begin with and then
it's just the
the time that you put in to structure
everything else around those
to create that film that's that's got
the emotionally satisfying arc to it
how do you know the ending's good or
it's satisfying for someone
well one good way is to test it with
people
pitch it to them i've done that a lot
school
taught me that you know workshopping
things is a great way to get out of your
own head
and get other opinions from folks you
know who are also writers and who are
also storytellers
and you know pretty quickly if you pitch
a few people
and you get sort of sideways looks
you know pretty quick that there's
something wrong with with what you have
if it works it works immediately
and that's true with a log line it's
true with any particular moment in a
script
you know if if somebody knows a
particular story and you're telling them
a part of the film you know immediately
if it connects
so that's i think that's that's one good
thing you know if there's any kind of
hesitation
i think that's a point where you need to
go back and review you know what got you
to this point
why do you think this isn't working is
there something you can change before
that
point to make that event more poignant
you know or scarier or funnier you know
whatever it is
but in my experience it's pretty fast
it's pretty quick that you that you
learn
by workshopping whether or not
something's working do you ever change
endings mid-course like you you you know
your ending when you outline and then as
you start writing
you've decided you know what i think the
ending has changed
yeah yeah i've done i've done that i've
i've written films where the beginning
ends up completely changing um i've
written films where the lead character
becomes another character
uh you know it's all it's it's a process
and
it's really trying to figure out who
these characters are
and trying to figure out why is this
character in this story
that's a question that i think you need
to answer when you're when you're
putting something together
um you know if you have a story about
you know like a revenge story
uh about a guy who's trying to get
revenge on song i'm thinking of the film
taken
you know you you think of what kind of
character
would fit best into a story like this
what kind of character has the most to
learn
by going through the experience of this
movie
right so for an example
i have a script that i'm writing um
about
a woman whose mother is running for
governor
uh in a midwestern state and
her mother mother and daughter have a
very very stressed relationship
mother's very ambitious she's had a
political career she wants national
office
things like that and the daughter is a
very meek person
just wants to live kind of a quiet life
kind of be you know off to herself
to be involved in a big media campaign
for a big political office is a
situation that
she would feel really uncomfortable in
so that's why i want that character as
my lead
because she will have the most to learn
by going through that process
so it's finding you know it's it's
finding a character to match what your
story is
and that can you know that can take any
any kind of flavor and it can go
in a lot of different directions reminds
me of um
ingmar bergman's forgive me that for the
name is
escaping me but about the mother and
daughter and the mother is this
classical
pianist or whatever and she's had this
tour and she kind of abandoned
motherhood
and then her daughter is this more meek
i think she might be like a social
worker or something
and she comes back after having been on
the road and even though sometimes if
you don't have the subtitles that that
are playing just the tension
is fantastic to watch yeah that's and
and that's and for me
families are a great place to find that
that's why i enjoy stories about
dysfunctional families
because you're these are people that
you're around in the formative years of
your life
so any any emotional deficits that you
have or any issues that you have
are primarily because of the folks that
you spend time with you know whether
it's your family or your friends you
know
kind of growing up those are where you
get those formative experiences so yeah
that's why i enjoy
stories like that
what are your five favorite
screenwriting books five favorite
screenwriting books oh boy
um well i have to plug the story
solution by eric edson
um i've written that book backwards and
forwards over the last two years and
it's fantastic
um i like reading screenplay by sid
field just because it's sort of
it reinforces the basics um i think
that's something that's really important
um i really like story by robert mckee
because that's kind of a more of an
esoteric
more of a it gets into
you know kind of sub genres and just
really really minut things
in in storytelling in terms of
classifying things which i think is cool
we don't do that much of that i think
that's really good
um there's uh one that i re there's a
it's not a book it's actually
um a record uh like a transcription of a
speech
um a guy named uh frank daniel
oh yeah he's a screenwriting instructor
and he's the one who created the eight
sequence approach
um he has it's like a 70 page
transcription of a class that he taught
and that's where he gets into kind of
the beginnings of the eight sequences
and things that happen within them and
stuff
um that was something i was given in
class and i think i probably read it
nine times it's
fantastic um you can probably find it
online
and then the fifth one
i would say save the cat i know a lot of
folks
have differing opinions on that book but
i think
that's kind of a neat fun way to figure
out the basics of what your story is
is by going through through that process
i think you need to get a little more
granular than save the cat when you
ultimately sit down to write
i've written a few screenplays with with
save the cat before i got to school
but i think it's really kind of a fun
way to get motivated to write something
so i think it's there's there's
definitely value in that if you try to
plug that into
legally blonde what i'm trying to think
that forgive me it's been a few years
since i've seen it so
does elle have a save the cat moment she
has a few maybe
to kind of prove herself and let me make
herself likeable
yeah i mean when she um
when she's nice to the woman at the uh
the hair salon
that's definitely one trying to think at
the very beginning
there's definitely i can't remember
saying the cat moment specifically but i
know that all the girls in the sorority
absolutely
love her so there were certainly save
the cat moments beforehand you can see
the love that the girls of the sorority
have for al
so that's definitely something and it's
been a little while since i watched it
too right did they love her from the
beginning though
i don't know if they loved her from the
beginning but then she proves
no the girls in her sorority love her
they do yeah she's the president of the
sorority
and she has a 4.0 if you remember at the
very beginning one of the sorority girls
has that
card that she delivers to her when she's
riding the bike through campus
through the opening credit sequence so
yeah she's definitely adored there
it's when she gets to harvard that it's
a problem oh okay
right the girls don't like her at
harvard and she has to convince them
but yeah when she first starts out
everybody's in love with her like she's
like
the the talk of campus sure sure
yeah you talked about room 104
earlier i think you wrote like a spec
script or you did something and now
you're actually working with
the duploss brothers yeah you talk about
that yeah
um so when i was starting to make films
uh the duplass brothers were idols of
mine uh i thought the puffy chair was
one of the
the greatest micro budget films ever
made i still think it's one of the best
um and i had really wanted to work with
them and i really wanted to
try to see a little bit more about how
they make stuff
so about this this story goes back quite
a ways actually about 10 years ago
uh the duplast brothers made a film in
maine though it was called blackrock
and if uh mark duvlass's wife katie was
the director
and kate bosworth was in it and like
bell was in it it was a thriller
yes okay really really great film and
when they came to maine they didn't have
any local crew
so the producer of the movie uh my
friend adela
she contacted me because i was living in
connecticut at the time and she said do
you know anybody that would want to come
up and work on this film
and i got her about a third of her crew
so
i as a benefit of that i got to go up
for a couple days and i'd hang out with
them for a weekend as they were shooting
and when i went there mark was there so
i actually got to meet him
when we were on set and absolutely
like fanboy the whole time like had a
hard time speaking to him but he
couldn't been cooler couldn't have been
nicer
and so we stayed in touch um so fast
forward
you know eight nine years when i moved
out to los angeles
i ran into him at an event for the hbo
show animals
that they had and i went to go see the
first couple episodes of that
and i saw him work there and i told him
you know i'm in la now you know i'm
working in orange county
so that was great and then
a couple months later he actually cast
me
in an episode of the first season of
room 104. oh my gosh
yes the show ultimately cut my part out
of the episode so it didn't make the air
but when i was there i got to meet you
know the director of the episode
obviously and all the producers
and then that was sort of my first
exposure to the folks that were running
their company
so fast forward again now i'm in at csun
i have to do an internship in order to
graduate so
i contacted mark and i said hey is there
any way that i can work for you it'd be
great to
to be a part of the team and he said
yeah we actually started a short form
production company
it's called donut and they make
commercials they make branded content
they make interactive television
they make all sorts of stuff and they
need help
so i started interning with them and we
worked on
a number of non-scripted stuff series
and a couple scripted
series back in december of last year
um i was helping them with like the
development of their interactive tv
shows
one of which is going to shoot later
this year i was an associate producer on
a web series that they made
so really got a chance to work with them
a lot
and that culminated after right after i
graduated in may
they're making a new movie and they
offered me to work
with them as a production assistant so
here i am 42 years old
uh the oldest production assistant in
los angeles and i spent a month
working with them helping them make this
film and
it was an amazing experience it was
really really great i can't give any
details about the movie itself
but being able to work with them um and
seeing the folks that they work with
and how calm everything was on set and
just how they work with great people
that's the secret to their success i
think is they just have
so many wonderful people in their
ecosystem that it's it's just awesome
so it was it was a really great
experience and i hope to to keep working
with them on stuff in the future
yeah they're very personable and they
have a great sense of humor too it's not
like it's just when the camera's on they
they
right right they're able to laugh and
just yeah they're just they're salt of
the earth guys they really are
and it's interesting how a different
little like what would seem like small
opportunities that some people could
just say oh well i don't know if i
really want to do this
is now turned in it just shows you if
you kind of stay the course
how someone can notice you it's so
important and the other thing to
remember too is that you know
tied into that it's it's a long game you
know you can't come into something
expecting someone to help you
if you don't help them first and you
know the fact that i got the opportunity
to pa on this movie
because i interned for them because i
gave them my time
and obviously it was a benefit to me
because i was able to work with some
great people
but they were able to do more as a
result of me being there
and had i not been there so that there's
there's a sort of turnabout for that you
know then they offer me an opportunity
on a movie you know that's that's how
this works you know people help each
other
that's how you get ahead so you know my
hope is you know if they have another
movie in the future
maybe they might ask me to do something
you know in another role maybe a little
bigger role
because i've shown them you know i think
i did a pretty okay job
you know as a pa and yeah we'll see
where it goes do you see that with some
of the students because things are so
fast-paced whether it's breaking news
i mean it almost the 24-hour news cycle
is no longer it's now like
it's the yeah the two-hour news cycle
and then we've moved on to some new
horrible tragedy do you think a lot of
younger people they don't realize that
things still do take a while
because it seems like some people they
want this instant thing and maybe that's
just youth
they don't realize that things do take
some time i think yeah i think youth is
a big part of it you know
what is it mark twain had that great
quote i wish i could be 21 again when i
knew everything
um that i think that's i think it's an
important growth step
you know for young people to realize
that there are dues to pay
now how you pay them is an open question
um you know some folks they they
immediately
you know go out and start making their
own films and if they find success
that's great but there's a possible
caveat that they don't have the full
understanding of what it is that they're
doing if they get success early
if that makes sense yeah and then
there's other folks you know
they come in and they start at the
bottom and they work their way up and if
they find success then
they have a little bit of a different
viewpoint because they understand the
different people that are involved in
something
and what it takes to get to a particular
position
so in my experience the students who
get into something and start working
their way up
they have more of a respect for the
entire process
and what everyone does and i tend to
find that those folks are
a little more knowledgeable about the
entire filmmaking process
and i think they're a little more
grateful for should they find success
that they had worked their way towards
it some film
students of mine they had gotten out of
school and
through resources of their family they
get an opportunity to make a film
and they make the film and you know if
it finds success that's great
i feel like they miss a little bit not
having an opportunity to
you know to work some of those jobs and
understand what it's like looking from
the bottom
and you don't have to do it forever you
learn a lot on one film
you know even if it's just one you know
you get a sense of
what everybody's doing and how important
every person is
um there's a different viewpoint after
you do that um it's not so much you know
i'm hiring you to do this
it's it's i understand how you play a
small part
in the whole of making this movie
so i think yeah i think that's that's
something that kids learn
eventually our age definitely has
something to do with it you know the
the instant news cycle is definitely
something that that reinforces the
instant gratification
and the lack of attention span uh that's
that's something that doesn't help
a mindset like that um
but you know i think most of the time
this town
is pretty solid in their attitude that
you need to start at the bottom if you
want to get anywhere
so i think i think la sort of brow beats
folks
you know into that kind of that kind of
path i think
what's the easiest year you've had as a
filmmaker i would say
the year after rising star was finished
was probably the easiest year i had as a
filmmaker
um i made a short that year that i wrote
directed and produced
that's actually on amazon prime right
now
yeah it's called protesters okay um and
that was
sort of the the joyful next step
after finishing a feature that literally
took everything out of me
when when we finished rising star i
didn't know if i would ever make another
film again
it was it took five years of my life and
it took a lot of money and it took all
my energy
and i wondered if i had enough inmate to
do it again
so this that short film was sort of like
the test
like would i be able to do this um i
wrote the script
with one of my actor friends in mind
from rising star a guy named michael
barra
and and he's great he's he just finished
up a national tour
of uh a bronx tale and he was on
broadway with them for a while
good for him yeah so he produced this
short with me
uh and we wrote it together um meaning
he
he like gave notes on all the drafts
that i wrote and then it was a three-day
shoot
and we did it and it was a blast
because there was no pressure we made
the whole thing for two thousand dollars
and it was it was fun we had all actors
that worked with us on rising star
previous
with the exception of one new guy who
was amazing
his name was norm golden he's a new york
actor he's great
and that sort of gave me hope
that i could keep doing it
at that point before we made the film i
thought that my future was going to be
back in producing
and just sticking with that but once i
made that short film
i felt a lot better about it and i
started thinking
okay you know what else what else can i
start making what else can i start
working on
and i had gone back to the script that
i've been tinkering with for like seven
years and i did a draft on that
and i acted in a couple films that year
that friends of mine were making
and so it was it was definitely
it was definitely the most optimistic
year um
in my career as a filmmaker because it
was sort of the beginning of my
building up to the point where i could
make another feature
i think what about the toughest year you
had as a filmmaker
without a doubt 2011
because we shot rising star in 2010
i was shot in october and we finished
finished right before november 1st and
the first week
of january in 2011 my father died
so i went all the way through
post-production
also grieving the loss of my dad um and
at the time it was one of those things
where i just i thought i needed to
just push it down and just just you know
get it over with
and that was probably the reason we were
able to finish the film was because i
did that
um but it definitely had repercussions
for me later on as far as like you know
grieving the death of a parent because i
really didn't deal with it
ultimately over the next couple of years
i would um
but that was that was probably the
hardest
you made rising star in connecticut and
i know that
the state of connecticut seemed very
supportive you know i you were
interviewed on at least one or two
news out you know and you had coverage
and i don't know if the heart for
current
oh yeah they did so you were really
embraced
and then coming to a state where
there is a film energy but there's so
many people doing it
how did that feel because you came from
being a rising star in connecticut
sorry i didn't do it
but and then you come here and i'm not
saying you're not a rising star but i'm
saying it's just there's so many rising
stars you're one of a million
right how was that because you have a
level head and you know you're
grounded it's all of the earth i would
say from knowing you thanks
um it was a challenge um
i think part of it part of why i did it
was because
the institutional support that i got
from connecticut in making rising star
was starting to disappear we had a tax
credit from 2006 to about 2012
and that brought so much filmmaking
activity and so much energy to the state
but in 2012 they stopped the program
and once that happened all of that
filmmaking energy was gone
within weeks it was just done
and i was sort of caught off guard
because
i like here i am i put so much time and
energy into this
and and i didn't really know what i
needed to do next
once that happened so i had actually
right around that time i actually
started a business
with two colleagues of mine that i
taught with at quinnipiac
and it was a production company and
social media services and
crowdfunding consulting we did with a
lot of folks from yale from the uh the
entrepreneurial institute there
and that lasted for about two and a half
years and we made a decent living doing
that
um but ultimately i wanted to be in an
area where that energy was there
and i knew it would never happen in
connecticut again
so it was just a matter of looking and
where did i want to go
i tried living in new york for about a
year um actually lived with michael
barra
oh nice and that was great and we had a
great time there's a web series
oh 100 we talked about that actually oh
really
yeah um and then
after that i came back home uh because
my mom was sick and i was home for about
a year and then
at that point i was living in
connecticut
there was nothing going on film-wise i
was having trouble finding
work so i just decided okay i just
need to go where the action is and
that's when i started putting out
feelers you know for jobs
in california and thankfully about six
months after that
chapman contacted me and you know said
we're interested in having you as our
production manager and
i got the offer and two weeks later i
was in california
this was in 2012 2015 2015. okay so the
economy
was more things had improved a little
bit right
right yeah because was it challenging to
to find jobs out here
well with your background you have great
background i it was it was different i
applied for primarily educational jobs
because i knew i was going to be one of
a million people applying for production
jobs
and i didn't live in l.a so i knew
if i was going to get something it would
be something that was a little more
institutionalized
so higher ed seemed like the natural fit
because i had taught
and i had applied at different film
schools i applied at ucla
afi cal state fullerton i think i
applied at actually
and you know nothing came of those until
you know chapman had reached out to me
and the reason chapman reached out to me
is because one of their deans
went to the film school at florida state
oh so when he saw that i was a grad
that's how i got that in so that was
ultimately it was the network
you know that ultimately helped me wow
to get that job
because you had such not just the
education but a body of work
you'd been through the trenches and and
to think that
it took that long to find something yeah
just shows you how competitive
oh 100 100 and i was so grateful to get
that offer because i had assumed nothing
would come of it
um you know just because i because i
don't know anyone out here
you know and it wasn't until i actually
got here that i started creating a
network
of la folks it was just a florida person
that helped me get out there
so it was a very very unexpected thing
what movie are you making actually right
after this interview
uh so once we're finished i'm gonna be
driving to agora hills
where i will be directing uh my second
feature
uh it's a film called stay with me it's
a drama
and it's a story about
a woman who's suffering from mental
illness and
it's about her best friend and her
boyfriend
and how they deal with the lead up to
and the aftermath of her suicide
so it's a it's heavy subject matter it's
not a heavy film although there are some
certainly
emotional moments in it um i met
the um the writer the co-writer of the
film was an intern of mine
when i worked at cal state northridge
and he was just
dead set on making an independent film
once he graduated
and he bugged me for about six months
and eventually i joined him
on on the journey and he said we can
shoot at my parents house
you know i can get equipment for free we
can work with students that are
graduating from csun's film program
and eventually i came around on it and
we decided to put the the team together
and i hired a group of actors that
had graduated from chapman university's
acting program
so those are all of our actors we had
like i said our crew is all csun film
graduates
and a couple chapman students that i
used to work with
and we're halfway done we it's a 13 day
shoot and we finished day 7 yesterday
so i'm on my way out there to work on
day eight today and
we'll have it done by next monday uh
and then we're gonna go on a post and
i'm hoping
by the middle of next year you know
we'll have the film done
so having made rising star in
connecticut and
different time different state different
world probably
what same things are you taking with you
or leaving behind
set of skills or you know
expectations there's no expectations on
this movie
um when we made rising star that was the
most important thing i had done in my
life
up to that point and i pressured myself
accordingly
uh this time there's no pressure um one
because we're making the film for next
to nothing
our entire budget's gonna be under ten
thousand dollars oh wow
um so that's a big part of it that's a
big help
but also you know this is not
this is not something that i'm looking
at as a linchpin in my life
to kind of carry me into another state
of being you know as a filmmaker
i've written and directed a feature
already so i know i can do it
now it's just a matter of how good can i
do it so it's a very different
mindset on this one and it's a very
different
process with the actors i find myself
a lot more collaborative on this
as far as actors giving input you know
on their lines and on their performance
uh the crew members that i'm working
with i'm a lot more collaborative with
them this time
whereas with rising star i had a very
specific plan that i did everything i
could to stick to
it's a lot different now and and
honestly i like it a lot more
this this kind of collaborative approach
i think definitely helps
and it starts with with adam mayman my
co-writer and my producer
he really is the energy behind this film
and i'm so
i sort of joined for the ride and that's
something i've never done before
every other film i've made it's always
been my genesis and i sort of
carry everything from nothing and create
everything from nothing
but now adam's really the driver of this
and i'm sort of along just to kind of
help shepherd it through
and bring my network with me and bring
my connections
and my experience and it's really been a
great
it's been a great time so adam came up
with the idea
we met for pizza last august um
almost a year ago this week actually and
he had an idea for a film that takes
place in two timelines
that's what he wanted to do and i said
okay
well what are some of the things that
you want to talk about what are the
things that you want to explore
and he said you know i'm interested in
lgbtq
issues and how 20-somethings are dealing
with identity
i want to talk about mental illness i
want to talk about grief
and grief was what stuck with me because
my mother passed away two years ago
and that was sort of like okay well why
don't we think of something that ties
around the death of someone close to
someone else
and that was sort of the beginning of
the evolution of what ultimately the
story turned into
so we we kept that sort of two timeline
idea
the film takes place in two separate
timelines the first one
is the lead up to the young woman taking
her life and the other one is the
aftermath of it
but the film cuts back and forth between
them so as to give the impression that
you know grief is a never-ending process
and it sort of permeates every part of
your life um
so that's that's kind of where we're at
and once we get into post-production
we're gonna
we're gonna play a lot with you know
time and what you see
and how things are juxtaposed present
versus past and stuff like that and
i think it's gonna be a good film you
and adam you met for pizza
and then how soon did one of you begin
writing
taking turns we we outlined the film
together
over about two weeks and then we split
up scenes to write
i wrote most of the timeline two stuff
that happens after
the young woman takes her life because
of my experience dealing with the death
of my mom there were a lot of events
that i wanted to put in there
that i had gone through and in
situations i had dealt with
and then adam handled the first timeline
sort of the lead up to it
and then once we combined everything we
just started tweaking together i would
do a pass he would do a pass
and we did i think eight drafts before
we landed on what we're shooting
did you have a table read with the
actors or no no time for that
no we actually didn't even cast
we had a very interesting process for
this um our other producer
a woman named sarah deleon she's also a
talent manager
and one of her clients had read the
script
and loved it and really wanted to be in
it so
i said to sarah oh i'm happy to meet
with her you know we'll talk about it
so i met with her very smart young woman
her name is laura fox
really had really deep insights on the
character
of katie the woman who takes her life
and really connected with her and
experiences that she had had
and when i met with her it wasn't a
casting session it was just
sort of almost like an interview and
when we were done
i thought okay this was the first moment
where i sort of jumped off the
the regular path or the path that i took
on rising star where i had to control
everything
i said i'm going to try something
different on this
i'm gonna cast her not even
seeing her perform outside of her reel
and the films that she had already
worked on and stuff like that i watched
those
was impressed with her work i said okay
i'm gonna
and i offered her the part and i said
listen i need your help
can you find me actors that you've
worked with
that fit these parts that you have good
chemistry with
and she ended up finding us the other
two leads in the film oh wow
and we've been working together and
everything has been
flawless and i was terrified and any
director that you talked to
would probably look at me with a hairy
eyeball and say you're out of your mind
for doing it that way
but when you're making a film for this
little money you can take chances and
you can try different things
so now i have three actors that are 100
dedicated to this movie
like incredibly dedicated they all have
an existing relationship so the
chemistry is already there it's not
something i had to create
and now we're off making this film how
smart
well looking at it now i you could say
it was it was a bit of a risk when we
did it but it's not just
people she knows it's the chemistry that
that's where it's really going to show
on screen
you know just because it could be
someone from acting class hey i want to
get you but
to know that if she's done seeing scenes
with them and they know each other
they've gone for coffee afterwards
whatever
yeah that's gonna translate they they
were all friends
so when we did our first uh actual
rehearsal
by an hour into it they're all hanging
out on the couch they're all lying
across each other's laps they're all
laughing and joking and telling stories
they've all worked with each other
before
two of them were former roommates oh wow
so it was
yeah it was one of those kismet moments
where you know
all right we've got three people you
know it would take 10 years of work with
me
of casting to try to find three people
with this kind of chemistry
so it really it really worked
what do you love about being on a film
set that has evolved
in my career when i first started
i love the idea of
being the sort of general
of a group of people that are out to
tell the story
that i have in my head and are helping
me
create it but that's changed
as i've gotten older i appreciate
just the act of being on a film set and
being part of a team that's creating
something
and now i think the the best part of
being on a film set
is being part of a team of collaborators
that's looking for the best possible
version of the story i want to tell
that took me a long time to get there
but now that i'm here
it's it's a joy to be on set every day
it's a joy to work with people that are
that are passionate about a story that
you know that i helped create but that
they have a major hand in
and giving them the freedom to
you know to give the input to give the
the thoughts on on moments that aren't
ringing true
and suggestions for things that might
work better
and being in an environment where you
know you don't have to be the one with
the best idea all the time
and knowing that you don't always have
the best idea
when you're in a situation like that
where there's people with you
and they can help you create the best
version of a movie
that's it's really a beautiful thing and
it's it's something that i'm really
happy to be a part of and it's something
i hope i can continue to be a part of
in the future how is being on a film set
similar to being in a classroom or maybe
the two aren't
oh no they're very similar um
being on a film set is a constant
opportunity for education
because there is never a film
where every person on the crew is that
is at the same education level for
everything
so you always have an opportunity to
point out something to someone to teach
someone
a technique of something to offer
suggestions to people and for people to
offer suggestions to you
and to teach you things you know i think
of it from a teaching perspective
because i'm a teacher
but on this set i'm learning things
that i didn't know mostly from the
actors like actors exercises and
how they get themselves warmed up for
scenes these are things i've never
i've never done so like i see them and i
see them working this happened yesterday
our two leads were they were getting
ready for a really emotional scene and
they were going through an exercise
which
i still don't understand where they were
just talking back and forth to each
other
the same motion like one will say i have
blue eyes
and then he'll say back you have blue
eyes and they'll go back and forth with
that and they'll change
based on things that they notice about
each other and
it's they they said it was a meister
technique and i need to learn more about
that
but this is something i've never seen so
you know even for me
you know the opportunity to learn
something on set it's very similar to
the classroom
and and i think you know generally
whether it's film or the classroom
if the teachers are in a situation where
they can learn things i think that's the
best environment
because if everybody's open to to new
ideas
you know the teachers leading the class
but they're not always the one that
knows everything
so if you know that i think that's a
really great opportunity for the teacher
to learn stuff
you know as well as for the students to
understand that having that
mentality will help them as well